lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hey
dude
how do you feel
how do i feel yeah i think the question
is how do you feel no the thing is how
do you feel about now all eyes are on
you dude because they can't see my face
bro on the [ __ ] like this i feel
mysterious and like at an arm's length
which is very cool i may sound a little
different to the people who just listen
to this podcast it's because why i don't
know his job
it's not really a nose job well it's all
good you know what though it's uh you
know what it is and my nose is gonna
look very nice once i remove this
band-aid it's gonna look exactly the
same well
you never know
i mean i guess
have you seen it without that on there
yet yeah so how does it look
did they [ __ ] it up no it's swollen a
little bit but it looks the same
okay so that means you didn't get a nose
job well
you know i had a deviated septum and i
went to the doctor and he said he would
fix it it was 95 blocked
on the right side
you and i have talked about this yeah
we've talked about this because you have
it too the last episode i think or two
episodes ago uh and i got it and uh and
it was three days ago and here i am back
at work now let me tell you something
dude
uh you know how raw i am right
like i don't we this is how we do it
here because we were gonna a lot of
people would just skip it right
and i want to give you the episode and
so i came and i gave you the episode
anyway even though
my i got a full-on nose job
you say nose job people i think you got
an actual cosmetic rhinoplasty yeah i
guess that's the term yeah i i i told
him right before i went to pass out i
was like yo dude make me look cute i
want a bigger nose i want a [ __ ] huge
nose like liam neeson dude did you go to
the same doctor that i went to when i
had my sinus surgery yeah why didn't you
ever tell me that that's so weird
because you asked me about him do you
know why no because i thought mom
[ __ ] probably told you
oh
well no she didn't
well i want the doctor to siri dude yeah
and he killed it i'll show you here look
boom there we go i don't need it joke's
on you
oh yeah you don't you look exactly
oh yeah i'm swollen
oh yeah you are small i'm smaller looks
a little piggy
it looks like you got a nose job well
because beautiful
you're like shiny around it because you
can't do anything around yeah i can't do
anything around it yeah so i don't need
that thing but the doctor told me to put
it on but i don't need it but you still
sound all [ __ ] up
yeah
why because uh there's stint in my nose
oh dude when i so i've had stents i've
had dents i've had two different pants
i've had
i've had two different nose surgeries in
my life one well that's too many one
when i was a a kid and i
uh ran into someone and their forehead
smashed it in my nose and my nose was
crooked and they i needed to get it
straightened out otherwise everything
would have been all [ __ ] up
in the world and growing yeah well it
turned out everything still got [ __ ]
yeah but don't do that hurts
don't touch it and
hurts uh
what they didn't tell me they put like
cotton way up in my [ __ ] brain oh
yeah they don't i don't and one day you
say this one day i was just hanging out
watching a movie with mom and i started
feeling something in my nose and i went
to the bathroom and pulled it out and it
was
i i was so freaked the [ __ ] well that's
gotta be so scary as a kid too covered
in blood yeah i was like 12 i think it's
like a horror movie yeah
kills it was [ __ ] up and um
the next one was when doctors and cereal
fixed my [ __ ] sinuses because i was
oh she had two she would put dude let me
tell you what happened before and but
now i need the one the [ __ ] you got so
i'm gonna have three oh that sucks and i
still got this big-ass nose i should
have haven't fixed it getting whittled
down dude yeah make it cute yeah bro you
know how cute you would be with a nice
nose that's the crux of how cute you can
be
with your face i think i look good with
a big nose though as a kid i hated it
yeah i think now as a man i think i need
the big nose i like big noses
i like big noses on chicks too you
hitting on me no okay i like chicks with
nice
strong pronounced noses okay as long as
there's no bum in it dude but no what
bump in it bump yeah bump i can't say
the p reverberates in my [ __ ] nose
hurts okay yes dude
just hurt twice all for the sake of
telling you yes dude the [ __ ] the p
the
vibration
yup oh yeah
lost your [ __ ] mind
yeah the m is way more the m is way
worse and i keep doing it
yes dude
dude here's the deal all right look
it'd be a little bit big lost your mind
here's
okay
a vietnam vet listen
so here's the deal my nose hurts i
[ __ ] unbelievable man it's all good
we're here we're raw right we're rock
cause we're gonna do the show anyway
it's all gonna sound a little bit
nasally all good
right
keeping it real
what
okay so gotta wear loose shirts so when
i take them off it doesn't rub up
against my nose and cause the deviated
septum to get all [ __ ] up what happens
when something like you accidentally hit
your nose i go like this
and i get so mad
but do you think like
drastic [ __ ] like you need to gotta go
back in and do it yeah right yeah why do
you why are you like that
that pisses me off that you'll like that
uh i was wearing my sunglasses like this
it's on my head they go bonk fell on the
nose hurt almost drove right directly to
the hospital but why are you like that
that's the better question uh i want
everything to be okay and most of the
time it's not gonna be okay and it's all
good i need to realize that everything's
out of my control talk about my
therapist it's all good yeah
everything's definitely understood but
so hold on a second now
uh
i want to tell you about when i went and
before we get into the episode i went
into the to get the surgery
um
and the [ __ ] doctor
is like you ready
and i was like he jokes you know he
doesn't he does so many jokings
hey
stop joking a little bit he does so many
jokings yeah so
he
is like you ready and i was like sure
they already had the iv in i don't want
to do this right of course who the [ __ ]
wants to do surgery yeah and he's like
all right here we go
but i'm in the i'm in this [ __ ] i'm in
this [ __ ] i'm not in the gurney yet i'm
in this [ __ ] right
so
i'm chilling i'm in the lazy boy chair
whatever the [ __ ] they call it you know
the chair that goes back and he goes
like this he takes a long
metal
uh what do you call it instrument
puts it up my nose i don't know what
he's doing i feel like he's just
checking or clearing it or whatever
should have known because i already know
what he did but well i don't know what
he did he didn't say i know what he did
but you did it i i didn't do that you
did surgery no not not not that okay i
already know what you're going to say
was not a shot
okay
i understand yeah he put a long [ __ ]
thing up my nose went so far up and then
just goes
and i go whoa and he goes all right next
one
and i go whoa and i say
what was that
no answer
all of a sudden feels like 120 ants were
released into my brain okay i don't
understand what's happening i don't
understand what's happening okay my
heart starts beating i i i go oh my god
right
ants spreading white plants plant plant
plant plant plant put an ant on that on
hat
marching ants all over my [ __ ] brain
that's what it felt like bro i'm
describing it again like a novel does
okay so that's what it felt like ants
just [ __ ] making its way around my
right so then uh but you know he didn't
put ants in your head right so but i
don't know what he did so i'm like what
what what is the deal why does this why
does this feel like [ __ ] ants
marching around in my brain all right
so
i say
what did you do and he says
i i i numbed you up there
and i go oh i didn't know you're gonna
do that yet and he says oh yeah we do it
beforehand and i said oh
so i'm chilling right
but i'm already a little bit activated
my heart's pumping and i'm like oh my
god oh my god so i say is this normal
and he says yeah and i said it feels
like you got my brain did you get my
brain wow that's such a dumb [ __ ] ass
question kind of joking though kind of
joking right but you i know you you
weren't joking but here's what i want i
want him to just be like oh dude
don't even worry but when you ask a dumb
question like that when you're joking
they're going to joke back now am i
going to be asking dumber questions when
it feels like 120 ants are marching
around in my brain now the answer to
that is yes right so he should take that
into account and have some bedside
manner and be like dude i know you're
probably worried but don't even worry
about this right okay but i say did you
get my brain and the jokester
you should have known yeah he goes like
this always yeah he says always i said
okay
hey but can you be serious right yeah
and he says no everything's fine too
late because when he said always
my blood pressure dropped to 40. it
dropped to 40 dude but why not because
i'm a resting athlete dude it dropped to
40 and i go like this oh my god and i
saw absolute pixelization
and i didn't know it but later on in the
day kristen told me i passed out
i said i did because i was so so nervous
but but you can't pass out laying down
hey do it
did it okay first first ever yeah i
passed out laying down did they pull
they've held my feet up they chris said
my body went like this
dude what the [ __ ]
dude
[ __ ] tell me when you're gonna numb
my brain you know
but he didn't you
i don't get it at all dude why would you
ask did you get my brain yeah you know
he didn't get your brand i know first of
all second of all you could poke through
if you asked it you knew he was gonna
joke back with you because he's a
jokester but i was already [ __ ] up
like and really nervous and then so
anyway he's like let's do it went into
the gurney after i woke up went into the
gurney and then he's like lay down don't
remember anything after that woke up
nose was [ __ ]
hurt to high hell
what happened when you got up
so
honestly i
this is the truth i tried to fight the
nurses and doctors physically
why do you know this did i tell you this
i think so i fought i i they the doctor
was talking with kristin in the other
room and the nurses say he's waking up
and he says ooh he's awake he's going to
be crazy i got to go watch this because
he knew i was gonna be crazy but there's
two things you might do when you wake up
from surgery
be combative or be very loosey-goosey he
probably thought he's gonna be lucy
goosey dude kristen said it hurt like
there was a they were trying to tame a
willie mammoth in the other room wow and
they were like
they were like chris please
they were like dude bro it was so funny
they're like
please chris you just had surgery please
just try to pin me down but what were
you doing
like like trying to [ __ ] swim get up
and roar
yeah wow bro it was [ __ ] funny
terrible patience i know they're like
cruising don't hit your nose terrible
patient wow
i mean i remember when i got
you took me i took you yeah and i got
you back and i and i woke up and i
remember thinking i don't even know why
i remember this but i remember i
remember telling you and the nurses that
i had to go i was in a hurry because i
had to get to the race yeah because i
thought i was a nascar driver i said oh
really
he said yeah i said are you a nascar
driver you're like uh-huh
dude it's so weird i hate that [ __ ] it's
so disconcerting to me i don't like
watching people like that i don't even
remember trying to fight the nurses and
[ __ ] yeah of course you don't i went
back the next day i apologized
yeah
just to apologize no no no i had an
appointment yeah i had to take the
[ __ ]
packing out it was awful dude it's all
awful it's so uncomfortable but now i
guess i'm supposed to be able to breathe
soon anyway yeah we should get into the
episode i'll talk about this more on my
podcast congratulations because it's
just me uh but before we even go i got
you some look
look what i got you
what does it do what do i open it up
it's a button
nope other way
nope otherwise so now i'm pissed now i'm
pissed and you hit it
oh it's different every time
so many different ones
okay so
you get these at crystallia.com dude
no one i'll ever interrupt you again i
got a free one
there you go
all right so
but i didn't interrupt you okay
wow that's really funny actually yeah
it's so obnoxious to have this imagine a
boss and you're just [ __ ] you're
talking and they're doing an interview
and they say something you don't like
you just go like that
so dick dude love it i would love to you
know be awesome if christian bale
brought it in his press junket for thor
love and thunder all right dude you'll
be like so what'd you think about your
character
um all right let's do it
here we go
what's up chris and matt
so my wife was raised to believe that
santa claus
and believing in santa claus is bad that
your parents are lying to you wow while
on the other hand i was raised
allowed to believe in him and and
just thought it was a fun and magical
part of my childhood i didn't think of
it as being lied to
um
when i was
dating my wife
uh
her mom
asked me so how do you feel about your
parents lying to you oh my god oh all of
your childhood oh and that like really
hurt me like yeah because i was just
thinking about all the fun memories that
i had about
their like
playing this santa claus character and
uh i had no problem with it yep um
and it continues in that she doesn't
want yeah our son to
have like the santa claus experience and
i'm like is this worth
arguing about in the first place
santa claus
let me know what you guys think oh
that is what the best that is the best
question yeah we've gotten so far and
the way he did it too was really nice
the way he said it all of it it was just
like the way he said was very concise
and good
i mean it wasn't that concise that was a
pretty long video what do you i didn't
think it was that long but mostly one in
the beginning of it i was thinking about
other stuff
okay so you know what he said uh not
really i know he said the thing about
santa
here's the deal i
okay i don't like when people
and my therapist agrees with this
because we were talking about what's
that thing where they hook up all the
stuff to your brain edmr therapy emrd or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
anyway
it brings up traumas that you don't
necessarily know that you have and it
helps you work through them and brings
them to the surface now my therapist
says there's two thoughts of it some of
them people think it's good because it
brings all your traumas to the surface
and you get to work through it but some
therapists think it's bad because
sometimes your brain is protecting you
from remembering those traumas correct
and you don't necessarily need to work
through them because you forget them and
that's okay so here's the thing this
guy's living his life having a good time
loving santa claus and then all of a
sudden this [ __ ] mom is like hey how
do you think about your family lying to
you and he's like oh i don't really
think of it that way and she's like well
you know that's what it is technically
and she's basically turning something
that was beautiful into something like
no you really need to think about this
and she's [ __ ] him up that's not on
her that's not him and he should be able
to raise his kid the way he wants to
raise her but it's her kid too i know so
here's the deal
say no stay in your ground why no he's
the way he asked it was right he's like
is this really something to put my foot
down about [ __ ] santa claus bro the
kid is gonna be shunned in school
no he's gonna be the one that everyone's
that is gonna be like ruining it for
everybody i know
they're gonna use their [ __ ] no no
he's gonna be the popular one because he
knows
i don't know it's it's [ __ ] up that
what the [ __ ] is wrong with your wife's
parents dude that's really weird i mean
it is lying but if they're not christian
then i get it but like if they're
christian and they're just like [ __ ]
no we tell no lies
what about all the christian [ __ ] well
that's lies they believe in it though i
know what the [ __ ] he should have
spun it back in his face wow what about
the [ __ ] about jesus rising from the
dead you believe that [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] easter every [ __ ] day
you idiot every every year you idiot
right so not the way to have that
conversation no you should have flung it
back in his wife's mom's face
what i think is it a christian thing did
he say that
no he didn't yeah but i'm saying
i'm saying the thing i'm saying uh which
is different than what he said right
which is
honestly you should be saying that no no
because i say
he says things yeah and then i say
different things in response to it i
mean i get it yeah okay
that's what the show is all right
uh i don't think that
i think your your wife's mom is super
[ __ ] up
i think that your wife was sort of kind
of deprived in a
weird [ __ ] way of a fun thing it's
just fun like [ __ ] whatever yeah
and i but i also think
don't [ __ ] fight about who gives a
[ __ ] really yeah dude who cares dude i
would go nuts if my wife didn't want
calvin to
have santa claus who cares
just give him [ __ ] presents
i i mean i guess but it's like what
about the magic of it and it's so sweet
you grow up and you're like oh yeah okay
i get it everyone was kind of just it
was a thing for a kid
kids it's not like it [ __ ] someone's
making any way you have to do it now
because i got all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the back of my nose but it's like i
got ants back there but um
yeah it's like nobody thinks
it's insecure nobody thinks that like
they're lies like this is something
that's wrong with the mother that's what
i'm saying like nobody's lying to the
kids but here's the thing the what the
wife you interrupt me
the wife got [ __ ] up
by the mom
yeah so it's not the wife's fault right
so just go with what the wife wants
because she's beyond [ __ ] up because
the mom
[ __ ] her up
it's the mom's fault yes
so let the wife let the wife [ __ ]
have it the way she wants yeah because
she's already beyond [ __ ] up yeah
and i guess [ __ ] up your kid but with it
and everything too and
perpetuate the [ __ ] upness i mean the
worst [ __ ] therapist
[ __ ] up it's like they're gonna fight
about it yeah i guess if there's gonna
be a fight about it just make sure that
you can just get your kids presents
and make sure that they can include
themselves in the day but i guess it's
not worth it if your wife's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy and be like hey no no
santa claus in our house because it's a
lie you know what i mean
yeah you're always like wearing makeup
that's not really how you look that's a
lie too how about do that yeah say that
oh you wear [ __ ] pumps you're not
that tall what about that you lied about
that like where's the line yeah where's
the line
either don't wear pumps or they're santa
which one something bad happened to the
mom when she was a kid with santa you
know yeah no [ __ ] man
but
unfortunately i mean you know what the
more i [ __ ] think about it
[ __ ] your wife dude wow that's that's so
[ __ ] weird dude you want to do the
thing to make your kid happy you should
be able to do it you're not lying
remember when mom told us there was no
santa claus and then dad was mad because
they obviously didn't have that
conversation together and that dad the
next year said you know so maybe there
is santa claus because we didn't even
know you want that you wanted that but
we but he still got it for you santa
knew and i was like yeah i know what
you're doing dude i i don't remember
that how old were we we were doing like
a [ __ ] way too old you know and mama
was like you know there's not really
santa and we're like oh really oh yeah
okay and then
later on my dad was like
yeah oh you know mom said there wasn't
no santa i was like yeah and she was
like well you didn't tell us that you
wanted that right i was like no and he's
like did you want that and i was like
yeah
then he's like well santa knew and that
must be santa and i'm like ah all right
man we're like we're in a suit yeah
we're like 22 you know
uh i remember i was like i was like 12
and i i i like cornered mom and dad yeah
like you're gonna [ __ ] tell me wow
that there is no santa claus i know
there is no santa claus you're gonna
tell me and they wouldn't do it
they still they would not do it i was
like you guys are being so weird i know
i [ __ ] know how did you know there is
no because i because i was i was [ __ ]
basically an adult all right and i
understood that there's no guy who
brings [ __ ] presents to every only
christian household and goes down the
chimney and is a fat [ __ ] and eats
cookies all night yeah okay i still do
that i believe in him okay well sorry to
break it to you but he doesn't exist do
you know where uh yeah okay well they
don't they'd say something like this by
the way i forgot to tell you dallas i'm
coming up i'll be in there soon
chrisley.com dallas get your tickets
it's almost sold out go dallas
chrisley.com atlanta chrisley.com these
are the ones coming up wichita
chrisleya.com uh and a few others go
check it out washington dc too all right
let's go to the next one
matt and chris what's up uh i love the
show i look forward to it every week i
apologize on advance for wearing
sunglasses i'm just feeling a little
ugly right now and it's all good there
you go
uh so
i got a blood test uh taken for the
first time uh in my life you know i'm 33
and the results came back that i have
high cholesterol and i'm a bit of a
hypochondriac so i was really worried
about it you know i did modify some of
my habits and all that you know i did
some googling
um but my you know as far as talking to
my doctor about it he's overweight and
the doctor yes i just wonder like can
you take advice from somebody who very
clearly doesn't follow their own advice
you know like obviously i would be
asking him like
you know nutrition advice uh you know
health advice and he seems smart and he
seems knowledgeable but you know how do
you feel uh about people who are you
know very intelligent and give seem to
give great advice but they very clearly
like don't
take their own advice
and uh you know i'm sure you've met
people like that before so uh you know
uh let me know what you think yeah yeah
yeah bye
uh yeah i think for sure he's clearly a
professional that knows way more than
anybody else in your life probably just
because he doesn't take the advice you
should so [ __ ] follow it it doesn't
somebody
i think this is a major misconception
somebody can be great at giving advice
yeah
just because they themselves don't take
it doesn't mean that it's less
good advice right two totally separate
things that's what you're saying like
that's why sometimes really good
teachers are failures
and what they did themselves right like
oh you can teach acting but why are you
not brad pitt
yeah because that's a totally separate
thing yeah yeah oh yeah you're good at
[ __ ] teaching but why can't you do
those who can't do teachers but no
that's not right you you can maybe do it
you actually probably can do it so
you're just
teacher right right you know so you want
to be a teacher and not make the
millions of dollars okay
no not everyone gets to make millions of
dollars well we're good
not even that good
so it's not about being good perhaps
it's about looking like [ __ ] brad
pitt brad pitt's backstack
um i i i uh
yeah i don't know i mean doctor fat
piece of [ __ ] first of all if you're a
doctor don't be a fat piece of [ __ ] you
know like be healthy looking right it's
like when you see a cop that's fat it's
like i don't know i'll run you
i'm gonna rob a bank of my outrun you
he's getting his gun now
yeah but wi-fi rob a bank right
oh wow yeah so you're quick
uh yeah dude i don't know man yeah you
can take advice from a doctor even
though he's fat about health yes you can
for sure right yeah because it's not i
mean you know maybe he's got maybe he's
got food addiction right that's
something oh hey maybe he's got
overeaters who the hell knows right just
saying he probably knows more than yeah
he knows more than you for sure exactly
you're free and easy sure uh so yeah
anyway i think that uh yeah listen to
your doctor you have high blood pressure
which sucks cholesterol
it doesn't matter same [ __ ] no
one they were they will they both lead
to heart disease right
i don't think so cholesterol does that's
the doctor that's the fat doctor but uh
honestly you'll be fine just follow your
guidelines to what the doctor's saying
and all that [ __ ] and if you have a
deviated septum get a nose job
like i did yeah okay go let's do it
hey matt and chris i'm katie i just
wanted to ask some advice about my job i
am a landscaper right now it's my fourth
season doing that and i'm a foreman i
have quite a few people on my crew who
are 19 20 years old whose first season
it is and i know it's a hard job to get
into and there's quite a few things that
just take some time and experience to
get the hang of but a lot of them also
just don't generally have a great work
ethic
and aren't listening to me when i tell
them what to do so
how do i as their foreman
get them to to listen to me or should i
maybe just let it go and stop caring so
much um any advice would be awesome
thank you guys
it's not if it's her business i get why
she wants them to care but if it's not
dude just do your job as best you can
and you can't control other people but
being a foreman part of her job is i
know work i know but what are you going
to do dude you're only in control of
what you're in control of right you need
you know what it is you need to be more
charismatic you need to be a little bit
more like and i don't mean i don't agree
with what he did but hitler right
because hitler was obviously really
charismatic okay yeah i'm just gonna
gloss over that entirely i'm saying
nobody would have followed him
[ __ ] yeah
they don't do what you say
[ __ ] yell at them all right that's it
no not no
no
no nothing hitler no right
uh yell at them and
threaten them that you're going to get
them [ __ ] replaced from the work site
right that's it
they don't do the [ __ ] [ __ ] that you
tell them to do then they're [ __ ]
shitty and shouldn't even be there in
the first place right that is a super
coveted job construction's true good job
like union [ __ ] and people people really
really want those people to need jobs
and tell those [ __ ] if you're
not gonna listen to me yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] get your ass on the
street yeah you could be like you know
you i'd say you're not gonna be familiar
but you know who hitler was and when
they'd be like yeah be like okay well so
what he would do is if you didn't do
what he was saying he would kill you i'm
not gonna do that right because uh it's
different time
but that's not really what hitler was
known for doing but
okay
this is you just different time right
this isn't the 40s anymore but uh and
also it doesn't matter what your
religion is but i will say um i'm not
gonna do that but i'm gonna replace you
and this is a very coveted job so
please
uh get to work and you know
join the third reg or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to say but why would you say
that anything about hitler well you
wouldn't but i'm just saying to like add
drama to it it would get people really
you meant all you gotta do is mention
hitler and people were like whoa whoa
what like right now i bet is the most
engaged time during this podcast no i
don't know most confused time for sure
because it makes absolutely no [ __ ]
sense yeah
um but yeah uh
[ __ ] threaten them and maybe do like
one of these like the thing where you
[ __ ] oh wow really you get to do this
oh you don't want to work
no you [ __ ] get up you just get up in
their [ __ ] and go like that i don't know
if that would work that's uh yeah i mean
you might as well mention hitler if
you're gonna do that no you you're gonna
get fired up close to him and you just
[ __ ] do like the like you're gonna
jump like that yeah i know what you're
saying dude for people that are
listening and not watching also i'm i'm
like pretending like i'm about to come
out fake like yeah yeah but also she's a
woman and most of the people are
probably viral 20 year old men
well that's probably why they're not
listening and that's even more [ __ ] up
sexist they're sexist dude yeah so get
them [ __ ] [ __ ] do get them [ __ ]
fired bye bye get them fired right
they're sexist that lazy get them out of
here they're not doing the job [ __ ]
reporting the higher-ups get them
[ __ ] out of there what the [ __ ] are
they doing yeah you know
get him fired she why don't you have a
donut necklace what are those necklaces
that people wear
i didn't notice i don't know i'm very
very very observant okay so you had to
donate that class anyway all right cool
well that's what you do go to the higher
ups and tell them and if you want fail
safe right talk about the hitler stuff
but that's fail that won't help right
next get a book on managing get a book
on managing worst advice
that's great
managing
written by
that's what that is you need managing
techniques yeah yellow them threatening
to get them fired
yell at them threaten to get him fired
you need managing techniques
okay
joey fatone chris matt what up
love what you're doing chris i'm always
in my log cabin have been you know well
you're in for life three years it's all
good hell yeah um
so let's get down to brass tacks okay
i've been dating this girl for a long
time
uh the relationship is actually going
really well
uh you know things are actually on the
up
uh well they've they've always been on
the up
um
however we both just graduated college
i'm going in into the united states navy
for you know the foreseeable future
um and i'm not going to see her like
ever like for a long time okay how long
and i don't know what to do i don't know
if i should break it off i don't know if
we should like set some ground rules or
like boundaries or if i should just like
try to slow burn it uh i don't think
it's very fair to either of us but maybe
it is i don't know i know that like i
would find myself getting really lonely
in a situation like that
um
so i don't know trying to keep it brief
uh you know i think you guys got the
gist let me know um
other than that though life rips keep
doing what you're doing guys i i love it
uh hoping you can get me this lifeline
though hell yeah bro listen you're in
the navy bro that means you're the
toughest of the toughest which means bro
you're the man this is what she wants
she wants you to say sweetheart wait for
me she wants you to say that sweetheart
i love you i want to be with you i don't
want you to i don't want to break up i'm
going to be away i don't know for how
long but i'll be back when i am we're
going to reconvene i don't want you to i
don't want you to i don't want to lose
you that's what she wants you don't
break up with her you don't break up
with her you don't break over but here's
the thing you're a navy you're a navy
whatever the [ __ ] you're in the navy
people are gonna you know you might be
gone for however long dude
she's gonna cheat no no dude you don't
know what real life's like she's gonna
cheat okay and that's and what you're
gonna do when you come back you're gonna
know she is right you're gonna know she
is because you can see it in her eyes
and she's gonna be like a little
different right you're gonna be like
maybe it's because i've been gone away
and they're gonna realize oh okay i see
she kind of had a thing with a guy four
doors down i get it and you're gonna eat
that and it's gonna be fine and you're
gonna move on to have a wonderful life
so here's the deal stay with her
she's gonna cheat
chill on that
eat it have kids after that
yeah i mean i actually kind of [ __ ]
agree with that there we go dude i mean
there we go
yeah don't break up with her don't break
up with her why would you break up with
her in fact the fact that you're even
asking makes you think you want to break
up with her so now i'm thinking maybe
not
maybe break up with her break up with
her maybe he just wanted to be on the
show and didn't really have a question
because i don't think she should break
up with her eat it dude things are
really on the up like you say do you not
break up with her yeah they are on the
up dude look at the guy he's fine he's
cool he seemed happy and you know you
don't know it's i i don't if if they
weren't on the up he would have told us
they're not on the up what should i do
but he said we're not on the i'm on the
up what the [ __ ] should i do should i
break it off i don't want to be unfair
dude she doesn't even want that she
wants you to say i'll i love you enough
to wait this [ __ ] out and yeah i might
stroke a few guys off in the [ __ ]
navy but whatever when i come back i
still want to be with you and yeah you
might [ __ ] donk a guy four doors down
but guess what it's gonna be fine we're
gonna wait out that [ __ ] we're both
gonna stroke a few guys and when i come
back we're gonna have some kids okay
way to go
dude it's like i'm not to get paid for
this or
well see
no i i don't even
think well
yeah well yeah technically you are
getting paid yeah yeah a little bit but
yeah
hey chris and matt what's up i'm calling
in basically from next door is downtown
la
ultramotive
anyways i have some advice to ask from
y'all basically i'm addicted to sugar
and how the [ __ ] do i get rid of that
like i feel like i live a pretty healthy
lifestyle other than that like i sleep
well i drink hella water i'm actually a
personal trainer on the side so the
workout stuff is completely fine it's
just a sugar thing that i feel like i
can't get over like i quit drinking just
overnight
i quit smoking cigarettes just overnight
but the sugar thing i feel like i just
can't get rid of also i don't want to
completely get rid of it i still want to
be able to enjoy sugar every now and
then i just don't want to have it rule
my life which i feel like it kind of
does sometimes so any advice would be
greatly appreciated thanks for
everything you do
whoa then she got tattoos on the inside
of her hand did you see that no that's
crazy
thirty percent of your thoughts are
about tattoos ah just saying man what do
you think a tattoo i should get the next
one uh
dude uh
that's crazy to be that disciplined with
uh that's that is and i think it's
because she doesn't want to totally quit
because she can quit things she wants to
totally quit it's easy you just
and it's gone but she doesn't want to
totally quit sugar so she's trying to
find that balance and that's what's hard
yeah or she's an addict and that's the
reason why she works out so much anyway
and she works out
because that's her
addict behavior and then also she's
compartmentalizing on why she doesn't
want to stop uh eating sugar because she
knows she needs it you know what i'm
saying what does she need well she she's
saying like i don't really want to stop
meaning she thinks she can handle it but
maybe she can't handle it yeah
that's crazy to be addicted to sugar i
mean i guess a lot of people are i
probably am a little bit i have streaks
where like i'll eat like [ __ ] two
pints of ice cream a day what yeah i
feel like for like a week yeah two pints
a day
no like a night like in a condensed
period like all at once like some marlon
brando [ __ ] you'll eat two pints at one
sitting yeah
holy [ __ ]
yeah i've eaten one i'm a hard addict
though i'll [ __ ] i get on a thing and
i just [ __ ] ruin it yeah oh wow yeah
uh spanking about yourself so uh all
right well so what about um
[ __ ] well if you don't want to stop then
what the [ __ ] is that she's saying she
doesn't does it too much okay that's the
trick though
you can't do that
the answer is you can't do that you you
want to stop you have to stop entirely
you can't be like i want to
you she has the answer in her own
[ __ ] question she was able to stop
drinking able to stop smoking cigarettes
but not able to stop sugar why because
she wants to still keep sugar in her
life a little bit enjoy it once in a
while but that's not how you can [ __ ]
think of it you can't think of it that
way so she needs you're saying she she
needs to stop or just not even bother
she needs to completely stop eating
sugar and or rather dedicate her mind to
completely stopping otherwise it's not
going to make a dent well i understand
that but like what about how like
sugar's almost at everything
so you're saying like don't even eat
fruit or you're saying oh she means
[ __ ] sweets oh well no some people
don't eat sugar they literally won't eat
fruit
i don't think that's what you meant yeah
well i mean like that's what you can do
like you know learn to [ __ ] love
blueberries or some [ __ ] learn to love
strawberries but if eating smarties and
you're wondering why your [ __ ] turns
purple if you're doing it too much you
know well that's not really her
her inquiry i mean i'm just saying that
happened to me though i know you ate so
many smarties that you should turn
purple i used to call them somalis i
know cause you can talk and i [ __ ] and
purple came out and i called mom
worst three steps of all time not not on
the phone
purple came out i called a mom yeah i
was like six and i i i was such a little
[ __ ] shitty brat and i wouldn't eat
anything except smarties that i called
somalis and finally eventually i took a
[ __ ] and i couldn't believe the color of
it and i called mom from down the hall
do you remember the color of it yeah it
was purple it was like a
straw
oh
dude yeah it's like a coffee bean straw
yeah uh all right when i was older yeah
i ate too many electric blue gushers
electric blue you know anything that is
something you eat that has the word
electric in it it's actually disgusting
and i ate like three packs or something
in one day what was your [ __ ] electric
blue dude why was you why is your [ __ ]
all different colors i got rainbow [ __ ]
i've had one color [ __ ] brown
you're [ __ ] missing out and you're a
loser
you're a loser because you're not eating
electric gusher you're a loser because
you you only [ __ ] one color you're a
[ __ ] loser no all right so i've i
mean i [ __ ] brown and also like tan a
little bit but like yeah i don't know i
think you got to stop you got to stop
cold turkey you can do it but right now
here's the thing you're young live it up
i always say live it up eat the sugar
dude spend your dad's money while you
still can you know i'm talking about
like [ __ ] live it up dude pretty soon
you got your own bills you're not gonna
be able to [ __ ] eat sugar because
you're gonna be diabetic they're gonna
throw you cut your feet off right yeah
so eat it until like my buddy delray he
ate sugar all the time until the doctor
was like guess what got news for you
your feet are coming off in two weeks if
you don't stop and he just stopped yeah
because if it's a life or death
situation or if your feet are gonna come
off the shit's gotta stop so wait for
that moment live it up baby live it up
eat smallies all day long make your [ __ ]
purple is your [ __ ] purple you're not
eating enough sugar dean's diabetic yeah
pretty he was
oh yeah yeah uh so yeah so
you know
[ __ ] man don't do it yet yeah what is
she 20 [ __ ] to eat
you know
she looked young i mean i don't know how
much sugar you're eating yeah that's the
thing it's like some people are like i'm
addicted to sugar and they just eat like
a [ __ ] snickers every other day it's
like you're fine yeah
i mean she looks fantastic you know it's
not like she's [ __ ] obese
but she's like she's worried about her
health yeah yeah yeah about being no no
i i know i'm just saying you think of
someone addicted to sugar that you think
of that might be like jabba the hutt
nah i mean look at me man well you're
not addicted to sugar thin as [ __ ] i'm
eating two pints of ice cream no you're
not though when's this time you ate two
pizza ice cream
three days ago and then went before that
years oh
this [ __ ] guy so
so you're not addicted to it no i'm not
addicted to it now but i [ __ ]
no i'm definitely not addicted to sugar
i'm not addicted to sugar oh the truth
comes out dude i just cross-examined you
and killed it yeah i'm not addicted to
children wow mine as well face it you're
addicted to sugar
wow might as well face it you're
addicted to
sugar
what the [ __ ] is that that's a robot
coming in and replacing it oh wow this
500 is obvious dude i wasn't obvious to
me i might as well face it you're
addicted to
sugar oh what is the sound the recording
starting
[Laughter]
might as well face it you're addicted to
oh [ __ ] dude i can't believe i got a
nose job i'm just like real pretty dude
i hear i hear it in your voice and it's
bothering me well dude i mean what do
you want me to do it's knocking me off
of
all of my normal thoughts because all
i'm thinking about is how [ __ ] [ __ ]
you sound
okay
okay absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with me
and my sinuses
all right let's go to the next one
babies
what's up papa chris uncle matt it's
your girl katie calling in from
nashville
let's go and jump into it shall we wow
so
i'm gonna be 25 at the end of july super
super excited to begin my quarter life
crisis um
and i've been dating this guy for the
past two months um who happens to be my
first like real committed relationship
um you know i dated around here and
there in college and stuff i just want
to do my own thing and he's like the
first one to really like stick around
which is nice
um so no complaints there
but here's the thing that's been
weighing on my mind um
so we met on the super romantic medium
that is tender and i and he knows this
but i never would have like gone for him
have we not met that way because he's
5'5 i'm 5 10.
um and
i know that some guys can feel like a
little bit threatened like
masculinity-wise around taller women
which like breaks my heart because
i myself have so much love to give i
just need a chance you know
um and and short kings need love too so
anyway um you know we've gotten side
eyes about this and
i just do this the whole spin move and
like that's that's my thing but like it
still weighs on my mind sometimes so i
just wonder like like what do you guys
think about that like why do you think
it's a stigma um have you dated taller
women in the past what was your
experience i'm just kind of curious
we're milking the [ __ ] out of it though
i just so you guys know like for
halloween he's going to be a koala bear
i'm going to be a eucalyptus treat oh
it's going to be great i love
love you guys uh thank you guys so much
for this podcast chris i will see you in
savannah hell yeah and uh matt love you
so much you're incredible you make this
podcast whole hope you know that
all right bye over and out i will be in
savannah chrisley.com but here's the
thing
dude you're trying to talk to i mean are
you trying to talk yourself out of it if
he doesn't have a problem with it then
there's no problem she she if you
listened what you clearly i did problem
she
just wants to know it sticks in her mind
a little bit this stigma and she's
wondering about what we might think
about it she's not
no problems anywhere she's just like one
she's in her mind she wants to know sort
of what we think about the general
height disparity height stigma between
short men and tall women but she did say
my heart goes out to
him like what if like you know like i
know that maybe there is like some she
did say that kind of [ __ ]
what she didn't say that kind of [ __ ] so
wasn't listening you know what i mean
listen 80 of it no no i did dude i i
don't you know let him be a [ __ ]
koala dude i i i have i ever dated a
taller girl hell yeah dude i did a girl
seven foot seven foot one once no you
didn't well that is true i know that
because there's no such thing i did date
a girl that was six foot once and with
heel she was you know
sick told you it was calls me i know i'm
[ __ ] i really am a tough drink of
water but
uh uh yeah i don't think i've ever dated
a woman actually taller than me but uh i
definitely do know
men
male friends who have dated women taller
than them yeah and
some guys have to all that matters
is if the guy gives a [ __ ] yeah that's
the only thing that matters yeah because
if the guy doesn't give a [ __ ] then
obviously nothing matters because he
doesn't care and then trickle down
nobody cares yeah but if the guy [ __ ]
cares if they're short but yeah if you
guys then it's a [ __ ] problem because
he acts [ __ ] weird
then it [ __ ] everything up you know
trickle up i'm cool with it
yeah whatever i mean it's fine you know
she's taller than me so what i mean
most most people are talking
what's that matter oh dude do you mind
if i have that lollipop
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] koala eucalyptus thing is
good though you guys sound like you're
doing [ __ ] great
keep it up
sounds like you didn't give a [ __ ]
five five is whoo boy though yeah that's
[ __ ] sure maybe maybe like i don't
know i mean he's not done growing
yeah how old is he
he's nine years old oh [ __ ] dude no no
no no no
on the center of that tootsie
dude [ __ ] hell yeah dude that's
awesome that's cool man five ten five
five that's crazy bro you know what have
him get heals
have him get heals not cause they don't
care if he doesn't care he would really
wear heels and just rock that [ __ ] no i
don't give a [ __ ] whatever
cheer please for dinner what was that
what was that two please
put the heels on
me and my chick
still shorter than her by three inches
uh
your five inches is
is quite a bit yeah yeah man uh
that's sick though what if he's got like
a fetish you know yeah good for him yeah
yeah true true if you like so good for
everybody takes all kinds man he's
[ __ ] killing he's a koala well if he
likes yeah well
wow 510 that's that's that's when a
chick
enters into you're tall
five nine yes but 510 okay you're very
tall for a check she's actually a tall
chick and she here's the thing it's not
that she's taller than him it's that
she's a tall chick and he's a short dude
yeah right that's a big discrepancy yeah
like nobody would be like oh that's a
dude and also oh yeah like you you're
describing you'd be like yo you know
frank who the short guy
right okay oh the guy with the [ __ ]
tall chick yeah the guy who's always a
lollipop you know i think in a weird way
it makes it easier though he's like a
short guy
she's a tall girl and it's like that can
become their thing they can lean the
[ __ ] into it when a guy is like five
seven and a girl's five nine right she's
not like a tall woman he's not like a
particularly short guy ah then it's like
a little bit weird right you know what
i'm saying oh i see what you're saying
yeah
they're in their [ __ ] roles yeah they
got it locked down they're good bro [ __ ]
it man the guy grew the guy's how he is
you love him that's awesome it's
obviously real love that's amazing yeah
dude yeah that that just goes to show
you uh
the tricks on tinder yeah the only story
i ever heard that made me actually think
tinder is good for yeah because no way
did he say he was five five on tinder
right
you gotta lead with that when you're a
dude you gotta be like i'm this how tall
i am ladies maybe not though yeah yeah i
guess so tricked her into it he tricked
her in her whole relationship based on
lies no
like the santa claus thing
yeah exactly he probably believes
probably still believes in santa claus
because i'm seething about that guy's
[ __ ] wow we should have said life
that guy's wife's mom [ __ ] pisses me
off all right well i mean you know she
needs a [ __ ] therapist or two wow all
right let's do another one all right
cool
yeah what up chris and matt my name's
delia it's just like your last name but
without the apostrophe did you guys ever
think if your last name was your first
name
i swear the mailman would 100 think
you're a blackjack
uh i'm not here to joke although i got
jokes for days i do need advice
so my husband and i are having our 12th
wedding anniversary in a couple weeks
and i have plans to get like super
dressed up and go out to dinner and then
drink 40s under a bridge
but i'm not sure if that's sufficient
for an anniversary and this year was
especially tough we have a one-year-old
which by the way chris when you talk
about calvin
it's like i'm staring into my future and
the future's so bright i'm wearing
sunglasses
so
i think maybe i should do something more
romantic
but it still has to be funny so any
advice would be much appreciated uh by
the way chris we're going to see you in
albany in november
very much looking forward to it all
right love the show guys thanks so much
oh what a sweetie albany i'll be there
christina.com um you know what dude
well you put all this pressure on
yourself why do you need to do something
special because the year was hard
you got a one-year-old well some people
value their anniversary and look forward
to it i know but i'm saying don't put
pressure on yourself have a nice night
out you want to go drink 40s under a
bridge go drink 40 centimeters actually
sounds good if you drink i mean i don't
drink i haven't had a [ __ ] 40 in 20
years but you are under a bridge a lot
yeah i am yeah uh i you know well i
don't know what do you think like go
have a nice dinner and do the [ __ ]
40s thing you drink 40s [ __ ] egg have
fun yeah so you're saying go to a nice
dinner pack the car with 40s in the back
just get 40s don't even do the dinner
don't go to dinner yeah skip the dinner
so be like honey i want to take you
somewhere and then go where are we going
we're going blindfolded let them out
under a bridge
yep have a 40's here's your fourth oh
right there alright your friend can help
you already but also why why is it on
her
maybe yeah no i don't know
why doesn't your [ __ ] husband do
anything [ __ ] him okay well you're quick
to the [ __ ] the other person thing on
this show on this episode you're quick
to [ __ ] the other person you usually the
man at least has a hand in planning the
anniversary yeah so what where the [ __ ]
is he but i don't know he doesn't want
to do the sh call in maybe he's [ __ ]
got something planned who knows that's
what i'm trying to say though i'm saying
don't suppose you don't know maybe just
don't plan anything assume he's gonna do
everything and have fun with whatever he
did he does yeah he will right yeah
dudes pretty much don't give a [ __ ] so
like you'll as long as you're happy
he'll be happy because the last thing he
doesn't want the last thing we want as
dudes is
you
to like not be happy because then the
whole thing's [ __ ] up yeah here's the
thing
i hate to break it to you if this is
gonna be bad for you to hear but he
doesn't care yeah he doesn't care at all
what you do for your anniversary right
right right you do right so do whatever
you want right he didn't go [ __ ] right
if you really wanted to do what he
wanted to do for the anniversary you'd
stay home
you'd forget and [ __ ] be like the
next morning was yesterday or
anniversary oh [ __ ] hey yeah 100
uh so yeah so i don't know i just feel
like do don't put pressure on yourself
is the key you want to go out and do a
nice dinner go out and do a nice dinner
if you want to go drink 40s under a
bridge go drink 40s under a bridge do
that [ __ ] but don't think twice about it
sometimes i feel like i don't have a
partner thank you
thank you
we are all full miley free we've got
enough contestants thank you very much
hollywood you know what that is though
do you know what that is that's stomach
hell is saying you're not good do you
know what i was doing yeah i mean i
think you were trying to do this song
by [ __ ] red hot chili it's a good
song that the song is gonna do it good
you don't do it i do it good it's called
the bridge that's why i did it
sound scary
[Music]
you're not doing so well with the
consonants yeah all right that's what
about the content oh okay stupid to get
those mixed up
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how you do it if you have nasal
reconstruction you just got [ __ ]
septum fix dude
that's so cool that i got myself to be
fixed
it will be when you can breathe
man it really hurts but i'm here because
we're all my babies we are raw dude pain
meds or what yeah i took coding a little
bit of coding today uh i took it early
on in the morning but i don't take it
too much
because i don't want it i don't want to
take it too much you should take it a
lot but i operate heavy machinery so
how do i want to be operating my
forklift when i when i'm on a couch sure
yeah uh so yeah
all right
okay next one
hi matt hi chris i'm a huge fan of you
guys chris i'm seeing you in oakland uh
when you're here look at that dude um
this is my situation i go to a bar
almost every weekend it's my favorite
bar but
recently there's this group there that
has been making me feel very judged very
looked at uh i feel very self-conscious
when i'm there now so uh i need to know
how to block them out wow um how to get
back to being at my favorite bar and
being happy they're friends with the
bartender so i can't really tell them to
f off
um i've asked you know their friends
kind of like is there an issue with me
and no one has anything to say
so
i just need to know how to block them
out what do i do [ __ ] the haters
let me know what you guys have to say
what
what what they're uncomfortable yeah i
know
this is incredible what could they be
doing see this is why when we're going
to do our live show we're going to have
you guys call in
uh and so we can ask questions yeah so
you can ask because we can ask questions
to you but
there's like a
it depends on like what level of
confrontation you want to do it yeah
because there's a version where you can
just be like i don't give a [ __ ] about
any of these people this is my bar i'm
going to go and i'm not even going to
look at them there's that right by the
time you go do it enough you'll forget
about it you won't even [ __ ] see him
there's anywhere from that to next time
you go
you make a beeline for them and sit like
between them
and yeah and and confront it in in a
really direct way yeah and so what do
you do is say oh sorry i thought this
was a free country right yeah are we in
iran where where are we yeah oh sorry is
this this is north korea yeah oh my
might be i thought this is america and
in america it's for kaj yeah right if
you said it like that you might not know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
uh my bee is a freak yeah i think i or
you and then you just say
so what is it yeah you know so what is
it why why well she might know what it
is even she might be
being cagey with us right but something
is going on and she this is her bar and
all of a sudden this group started
coming in uh
that she thinks is judging her maybe
eyeing her making fun of her or
something yeah i mean you could go up
and be like yo what's the problem what
is it yeah that's what i would do sit
between them and say what is it okay
well but here's what is it that's very
confrontational yeah but also you could
do it in a non-confrontational way and
just be like hey what's going on do i
make you guys uncomfortable you know
that's pretty confrontational but but
like why are why i feel like there's
this thing here going on what is it
right because we don't live in [ __ ]
north korea there's america's for
country and i could be here but make me
feel uncomfortable right yeah so like
you could do that ask them and then who
knows maybe they become your lifelong
friends right
maybe yeah i mean that could is be how
the story ends but
i wonder what the [ __ ] you know what i
mean
i don't know what's wrong but uh
you could you know do it this is the
move
send him around
right uh
send them around to [ __ ]
say
and see how they react right yeah that
could be sending out the olive branch
right hey what's going on i i just want
you to know i got your [ __ ] i got you
around here's a round of you know
absinthe or whatever the [ __ ] you want
to give them yeah and then when they
drink that [ __ ] they're gonna be having
a good time they're gonna think that
you're you're the [ __ ] and then maybe it
will squash everything but why if not
then you know the problem is on that
because you you let out an olive rich
right but what's the [ __ ] problem
well we don't know
she's not telling us but she didn't do
anything
well you don't know that so [ __ ] them
all here's the thing
i killed their family right
she's not letting us know something
i think she goes in next time she goes
there she goes and sits between them and
says real loud so what is it no that's
they're just gonna be like what is it
huh yeah okay let's do that let's act
that out okay ready here we go i'm
walking in so funny hey phil okay i just
sat down no you don't have to just sit
there
so what is it
uh so
what is it
what is what are you turning us what's
what's the problem
what's the problem you got you're too
loud is the problem now at this point
no but you'll you'll you'll break him
down
you you it's not [ __ ] you know what i
mean war i think it is though i think
it's whatever she's leaving [ __ ] out in
a way isn't it i think she's leaving
[ __ ] out and i think whatever it is
if she's if it's [ __ ] up enough for
her to call in something's up
something's going on and she wants to
stick a claim and say it's her bar
she needs to [ __ ] swing her dick
around so to speak yeah not dick because
she has a vagina right no i don't know
but i think that what you should do is
definitely just
send around and see how it goes from
there you could try that first yeah do
that first if it's nice you'll you'll
see you know the bartender being like
yeah
it's from my heart yeah and then it'll
be like oh okay and then
oh thank you oh hey you know but this is
the thing if you [ __ ] their friends or
their boyfriends that's not a thing to
do right yeah because we don't really
know what's going on so send a round of
drinks unless you know secretly that you
did something you're not telling us in
which case then you just got to put your
[ __ ] hater shades on right and block
them out yeah i think that's probably
gonna end up being the best thing
anymore okay sure send them around see
what happens yep
yeah cool all right great perfect
next one last one
hey matt and chris this is lindsay i'm
leilani we're sisters we are sisters i'm
at the hospital i'm in labor
i'm gonna deliver my second child's suit
i wish the machine wasn't beeping in the
background that's like freaking driving
me nuts oops but it's okay um we we move
on
um we wanted to ask for some advice
about
creating our own podcast we have been a
fan of chris's for a long time and since
listening to lifeline and listening to
you guys have a good time and goof off
and stuff it's inspired us to start our
own podcast however we have no flippin
idea what our content should be so if
you guys have any ideas or suggestions
let us know or advices on how to get us
started let us know
thanks so much life rips cute look
you're not going to know you're not
going to just start did i start my
pocket i said no was going to be about i
still don't know yeah but you get a
following if it's good if you guys are
good if there's something about you that
you like
that people like then they'll tune in
they'll tune in also you got to have a
podcast you're a person and everyone in
the world has a podcast now yeah okay
even people that don't even should even
people that shouldn't have podcast
honestly so whether you should you
shouldn't you should have one because
everyone has black because they're
people at your person right yeah people
you know you could be like the it could
be [ __ ] uh whatever it is
you know sisters right
sister sister podcast i think that might
exist but
dude you could do it sister's in labor
always yeah yeah sisters in labor uh
yeah i don't know man i mean like you
got to have a podcast you're a person so
try it right i think if they're looking
for there to be a topic though i think
the answer is what are things that you
both bond over as sisters
because if you don't want to just be
like [ __ ] congratulations where you
just talk about [ __ ] no
and [ __ ] the entire [ __ ] time no
matter what the topic is hard hitting
issues no
we talk about the hard-hitting issues if
you want it to be a topic it has to be
something that you already bond over you
can't like reach out and be like oh i
want it to be about [ __ ]
every sucker is nish anyway right now
nowadays right that is the [ __ ] like if
you love episode five of the mandalorian
then make it just about episode five of
the mandalorian those people will find
you dude because people will find you
you know they got [ __ ] office ladies
or whatever it's like one of the most
popular [ __ ] it's about a did they do
a podcast on a tv show yeah what the
[ __ ] is i don't know they got another
one the [ __ ] doctor's one with the
the [ __ ] guy
from uh scrubs the two guys from scrubs
oh they do just they just talk about
scrubs this [ __ ] was 900 years ago what
the [ __ ] and they just talk about a show
that was on [ __ ] it was like if bea
arthur had a show about golden girls dog
i mean that would be better than the
ones yeah well especially because she's
dead it would be impossible for her to
do but
uh yeah dude i mean like
did find the specific thing that you
guys love that's great advice
get that niche because everything's an
issue anyway unless it's a marvel movie
and let's face it you're not a marvel
movie right no podcast is so
just find what you love with your sister
and what you bond over and [ __ ] go
from there that's definitely it and your
first few episodes they're gonna be
clunky as [ __ ] it's gonna be bad right
and you're gonna learn how to do it and
you're gonna find your way just like
your audience is
maybe through record episodes
and if they suck don't even [ __ ]
post them i've done that my first one i
never posted really yeah congratulations
it's the hidden episode that no one will
ever hear you don't does it exist
anywhere is it deleted i have it it
exists yeah we have it maybe i should
put on my patreon who knows but sell it
to one person
like it's a [ __ ] nft like for like a
million dollars like the wu tang album
that was just one of them yeah and the
guy who [ __ ] made that age cure
bought it
wasn't aids markers
hiv thing right no no it wasn't what was
it what was that it was diabetes what
was it no
it was aids it wasn't [ __ ] aids
dude i think it's hate
well there's no [ __ ] aids cure so no
well whatever it was it was close to
aids no there's that's not something
close to aids martin shirelli on the
aids spectrum arthur farnzarelli martin
scrubby isn't that guy in jail now
he's out he got out what do you get like
what was it for and it was for deviated
septum parasitic infections what a prick
that guy was dude yeah but look at him
cost
13 and he raised the price to 750 a
towel oh my god oh my god like
you know
i don't of course you go to jail for
that but yeah but also look at him you
shouldn't that's a guy that looks so
much like he would be in jail and so
much like a shyster look look at his
face like a black white coat look at his
face you go like this uh your honor i
i would like to call to stan this guy
and then he goes up arthur fonzarella
goes up and he's like look this is him
and this is his face book him and the
judge goes i agree
900 years or whatever look at his face
arthur fonzarelli you know whatever the
[ __ ] is that
uh
martin shkreli shkreli
martin scrotum okay wow so [ __ ]
immature dude that's it for this episode
right that's it man
so uh how's your nose oh it hurts
oh it feels like [ __ ] 100 bees are in
it it's looking it looks shiny it's
shiny yeah and it looks bigger because
because i can't wipe it i can't wash it
the only person to ever get a nose job
to make the nose bigger yeah i said i
want that liam nation okay yeah uh so
whatever this is the nose job episode
and i appreciate you guys listening
watchlifeline.com that's where you can
go watch lifeline.com if you have a
question uh subscribe to the channel and
subscribe to super cult this is the
super cult uh studios and we do uh other
shows here too that have yet to come out
uh so be the first to know by
subscribing and also go to chrisley.com
for tour
and chrisley.com for
the oops button uh you guys thank you
very much and uh i just want to add one
little thing to this no so
many of you yeah
dm me and ask me
hey how do i submit a video for the for
the show dude and i'm gonna [ __ ] tell
you now and again and again and again
go
to the [ __ ] link in the description
below or [ __ ] just go to
watchlifeline.com they just want to they
just want to talk to you dude honestly
it's [ __ ] well then ask me something
else that i'll actually respond to no i
know but here's the thing though
don't respond to them i don't that they
are crazy and i will tell you this much
dude i'll be ready for the rest of the
day uh you
uh can just go to
watchlightlife.watchlifeline.com
and do the [ __ ] and [ __ ] send us a
video it's all gonna be good it's all
fine okay
okay
your character from true
[Laughter]
dude
love you guys
[Music]